réunion ce soir à l'elysée où emmanuel
macron accueille les partenaires
africains de paris en marge du sommet
afrique europe prévue cette semaine à
bruxelles au programme des discussions
le mali notamment pays pour lequel le
président français pourrait très
prochainement annoncer le retrait des
troupes françaises qui pourraient être
redéployés dans les pays alentour pareil
prévoit de quoi ordonné son retrait avec
la mission de l'onu à bamako et la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali la france devrait
continuer d'apporter un soutien aérien
et médicale dans la région pour en
parler sur ce plateau régis que ceux
menés grand reporter pour rt france
bonjour
régis un jour qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de cette réunion ce soir à
l'elysée entre emmanuel macron et les
partenaires africains de paris alors
c'est pas une réunion vont être décidées
à mon sens des choses fondamentales
puisque mais c est peut-être une manière
aussi pour la france de revenir dans le
jeu et de réaffirmer qu'elles peuvent
être quelque elle va pour être la
nouvelle donne de la premar cannes
puisque vous savez depuis le 11 juin
dernier emmanuel macron maquereau a
annoncé pour 2022 justement la fin de
l'opération barkan ce qu'on a appelé l'
euro déploiement c'est à dire l'abandon
en gros du nord du mali bla la cession
du nord du mali aux forces armées
maliennes et leur déploiement sur la
zone des trois frontières c'est-à-dire
en gros entre gossip dans le gourma et
ménaka dans le liptako le maintien de
trois bases actuellement donc avec les
tensions qui existent entre le
gouvernement malien et les autorités
françaises il est question aussi qu' une
partie de ces des troupes qui sont
actuellement sur place soit retirée et
que en effet hier au déploiement
rené vraiment où ça ça va être discutées
avec les partenaires
on sait déjà qu'une partie des troupes
qui était qui se trouvaient notamment
les forces spéciales qui se trouvait
dans la zone de tessalit ton été
commençons maintenant au tchad donc il
ya voilà il ya déjà eu des mouvements de
troupes
comment au mois de décembre les comment
les france françaises ont remis les clés
des bases de
de tombouctou aux forces armées
maliennes donc déjà il ya déjà eu un
comment un réduction de la présence
militaire et ce redéploiement justement
vers cette zone des trois frontières là
actuellement le problème principal étant
de réamorcer peut-être une forme de
dialogue après l'en face verbale qui ait
eu lieu notamment entre le ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
et comment choguel maïga le premier
ministre malien il justement quelles
relations futures entre paris et bamako
ça c'est toute la question est là
question aussi va être de se positionner
quand le mali dit qu'il entrevoit de dhs
et d'autres partenaires qu'il
al'impression finalement d'un point de
vue ma vie à que les mettez français
comme on lève le camp et que du coup le
mali justifie cette réduction ou ça rend
tout cas cette comment amoindrissement
de la présence de marc khanne part il va
falloir nous trouver d'autres
partenaires alors qu'on se trouve
d'autres partenaires d'où évidemment les
discussions qui ont lieu même s'ils ne
sont pas officiels ni reconnus par le
gouvernement malien avec la smp wagner
les discussions qui ont lieu avec le
gouvernement russe qui existe déjà
également et aussi la possibilité selon
moscou
les troupes wagner n'ont rien à voir
avec les autorités n'ont bien sûr mais
on est au moins au sergueï lavrov a
affirmé qu'il y avait des discussions
entre l'armée russe et les autorités
maliennes donc il ya aussi un canal un
canal officiel il ya aussi également une
possibilité qui est des discussions ce
qui s'ouvre avec la turquie vous savez
qui est très présente dans la région qui
a notamment d'un point de vue économique
peser notamment reconstruire des
infrastructures l'aéroport de niamey
d'autres d'autres aéroports dans la
région dont il ya ya voilà d'autres
possibilités le mali veut se réserver la
possibilité d'avoir d'autres partenaires
que la france est la france évidemment
voit d'un mauvais oeil l'arrivée d'une
milice composée de mercenaires alors que
ses propres troupes sont encore sur
place la question pourra t-il exister
dans le futur une cohabitation entre ces
deux forces pourra-t-il finalement
peut-on imaginer qu'une armée régulière
comme l'armée française coexiste avec
une armée entre guillemets une ministre
de mercenaires c'est assez difficile
actuellement donc il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui de savoir quel va être
l'avenir de la présence française au
mali et qu'elles vont pouvoir être
aujourd'hui les rapports entre le
gouvernement malien le gouvernement
français et quid de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
parce que c'est ça et gamme dont il est
question si la france quitte le mali
qu'est ce qui va se passer après
vis-à-vis des jihadistes est ce qu'ils
vont gagner du terrain ou pas alors la
vraie question elle est que en huit ans
de présence française au mali là la
situation sécuritaire s'est dégradée la
situation aussi socio économique du pays
s'est dégradée on peut qualifier
aujourd'hui le mali d'état failli c'est
à dire d'un état qui n'arrivent pas à
assumer le contrôle de l'ensemble de son
territoire dont des pans entiers
aujourd'hui sont livrés à une activité e
néante au niveau économique est en tout
cas à des bandes armées qui sont
djihadistes ou non jihadistes il ya un
certain nombre de postes frontières par
exemple au mali qui ne sont pas assurés
la quasi totalité des postes frontière
entre le mali et le niger ne sont pas
comment il n'y a pas de présence
militaire malienne danse dans ces
endroits vous avez des endroits où le
sur le la pression des groupes
djihadistes ce qu'on appelle les est ce
que les militaires appellent le les gâte
les groupes armés terroristes et bien
les militaires maliens vont quitter ces
régions là ont quitté ses villes ses
villages et qu'aujourd'hui la grosse
difficulté en huit ans et que les
maliens ont vu la situation se dégrader
considérablement ce qui ne veut pas dire
que les français n'ont pas obtenu le
résultat les français ont eu des
résultats considérables dans la lutte
contre ces groupes armés la plupart des
chefs ont été éliminés et les français
sont toujours à l'offensive j'en veux
pour preuve en ce moment là l'accent
particulier qui aimait qui est mis dans
la traque justement de ces groupes au
burkina faso où l'armée française est en
tout cas les forces spéciales et aussi
des éléments de mark and track avec
succès et ont énormément de succès dans
les semaines qui viennent donc le
paradoxe c'est que d'un point de vue de
la lutte contre le terrorisme on a des
succès mais d'un point de vue la
reconstruction du pays c'est l'échec est
aujourd'hui et c'est
c'est le le le paradoxe de barkan c'est
à dire la mission de pacification du
sahel a échoué et que face à sète cet
échec est bien il faut en tirer les
conséquences et voir quelle va être quel
peut être l'avenir de la présence
française dans la région
régis le sommier dernière question très
rapidement on arrive à la fin de ce
journal
s'il doit y avoir une annonce donc une
confirmation du retrait des troupes
françaises du mali faire cette annonce à
60 jours environ du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
c'est pas un peu électoraliste alors
faire cette annonce du retrait dans la
mesure où ça compte trois soldats
français sont morts au mali ça va
forcément poser la question de qu'est ce
qu'on allait faire là bas quel était le
sens de la mission on sait qu'au début
il était clairement identifié il
s'agissait d' arrêter et d'endiguer
l'arrivée des colonnes dit à dist
composé de touareg et de miliciens
libyen qui venait comment conquérir le
mali et qui menaçait bamako ça c'est la
première opération l'opération serval
qui a été un succès et qui a apporté une
certaine popularité aux français dans la
région et donc électoralisme journée à
la fin du jt le problème c'est que huit
ans plus tard on peut se poser la
question d'une force française qui est
perçu par les magna comme une force
d'occupation ou une force qui rockin qui
ont fait recompose la françafrique
d'autrefois nous la montée du sentiment
anti français au mali maintenant d'un
point de vue des français oui la
question s'est il va falloir expliquer
ce qu'on allait faire pourquoi on sort
maintenant et quid des nerfs ceux du
sacrifice de nos soldats dans la région
merci régis au sommet d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
grand reporter arte france est là